hi guys today I'm playing a demo for you
called through the woods it's supposed
to be a psychological horror it's on
Kickstarter at the moment but it's only
got about a day or so left so it might
actually have finished by the time I
upload this but it does have quite a few
backers and people are saying pretty
good things about the game it seems
interesting it says through the woods is
a third-person psychological horror
experience about how far a mother would
go to save her son
this is Christian Peterson speaking and
I'm sitting here with Kevin Dahl the
mother of the missing boy Philip Todd
Erikson tell me about what was his name
again
Oh Nick do you mean old Eric right old
Eric sorry I always thought he was this
urban legend you know go to bed or old
Eric will come and take you that is
until I saw him with Philip before he
took him from me just for the record you
saw old Eric kidnap your son yes
so Oldroyd source is on the island my
eyes adjusted to the dark quite quickly
on the other hand flashlight I love her
beanie oh oh oh
yeah for some reason he likes collecting
them can I jump nope
what it is that one of the reflectors
okay so this is the woman trying to find
his son old Eric it's funny cuz it's my
older flatmates name it was an old banjo
picking up there wasn't any reason to
bring it with me oh but it's so cute
though fine is the older kids a folklore
person he was told to make kids be
bigoted when I saw the second one I knew
it was him he was leaving their doors
behind so I could follow him what a
smart kid
oh look at the sky oh that's fizzy I
want to go to the woods woods at night
is safer source it's it's hard to put
into words really it wasn't just the
forest but the darkness on the island
itself
it felt thicker almost alive I was a
threat to it it's kind of I don't know
trees a little bit dead aren't they yes
especially here that's cool it's
annoying that I can't run though push
shift and run oh look
shift makes me run I should already know
this by now but I can't jump through to
you to have previous conversations
Carrie I couldn't help noticing that you
hardly speak about your son's father why
is that I've told you everything that's
worth mentioning about him he just calls
to check up on us every now and then
whenever he's sober enough to college he
actually stopped by for Christmas last
year he had a gift for my sons this this
bright orange bubble jacket why you
shouldn't do that your son stopped
wearing his jacket as Cuzzi misses his
dad come on
might be a drunkard but he's still his
dad so I'm not sure if this will just be
one of those games where it's all
narrative kind of like dear Esther or
something like that we'll see there were
screams when I watched the trailer for
it so I'm guessing something happened
somewhere but I'm quite happy just
listen to them speak
Russell don't fall through there that
does not look ah very sturdy I was just
looking to see if there's a troll under
the bridge there's not though we can we
can carry on no we are so often on the
island I think they're a good reference
point to go back to if I get something
wrong in my story mushroom I hear
singing it's not a banshee is it
no they wail don't mean they don't sing
she's a nice singer God puts me at ease
a little bit she's stopped okay there's
a cabin oh geez Jenna where's Phillip
so wait does she think this thing is
coming from her boy because I would say
it's coming from a woman
it's been so long since the Pater horror
game
hello that way
no oh I can't get that way anyway okay
the singing stopped I don't know why it
was even there
can I go in here hello knock-knock-knock
oh I can oh I can't oh hello look it's
my face I'm a blonde okay go go go
she liked following thrusters up when
she runs I keep on thinking that these
little logs down here bodies for they're
not that is true roots there's a pan on
here get some food
Philip I can hear scrap scratching on
the door it was just a branch come on I
can do this
no that's whoa whoa I can't feel it my
red said my Reds are cheeks no my cheeks
are red was wrong with me it's gonna
slam now do it oh my what the hell
please get the weapon Oh Jen let's just
stop picking up and I don't know why
okay just to run out of here because I
don't like this no no no no why did she
pick up the ax
it sounds like okay it's a gremlin just
remember it's a gremlin it's not real
it's like a little it's not real all my
head what do I talk it's a gremlin it's
all real this reminds me oh wow what's
this hmm that's cool like a totem pole
but not um what was I talking about
oh yeah I said this annoys me when I was
a kid and my dad used to live by the
forest I used to take my little brother
out and nice to tell him about all these
horrible things that would happen in the
forest and then he would get scared oh
my and then I would tell him that there
was magical fairies that would protect
us in the forest so that we wouldn't be
killed by the crazy axe man who is now
old Erik I'm guessing where am i doing
okay Wow
I did not like to see a troll that was
amazing
oh my gosh I wish I took a better look
but I was just so freaked out I couldn't
I told you I was looking for a troll I
know was a troll oh my gosh she can't
run anymore by the way just so you know
she's reading akkad Wow I just I'm stuck
what a baby oh my gosh
whose eyes okay babe that was amazing
how would you describe what you saw in
the kingdom so it's one choice that
horrifying behind by children children
taken away from their homes away from
their parents yes hello games don't show
up their last memories take one of the
wooden swords protect yourself I can't
believe she didn't pick up an axe oh
you're not focused hello
yeah there you go sorry okay so are we
gonna get to meet old Erik is this just
a land of whom folklore no oh it's her
the founders jacket in there tell me how
did that make you feel what I felt don't
did was fury I became obsessed with
hurting him I wanted to tear him apart
I wanted to kill old Erik
Wow that noise
to be continued but I wanted to see what
rolls so I am go and check out the troll
a bit more I really want to jelly
okay right I'll just do it all over
again now I'll turn you back on when
I've got the troll in my mints
okay shall we stick around and see maybe
what's making that awful noise when I
get inside slam hello what is it
where are you oh my gosh okay where do
you come from troll where is your little
hiding spot
you up here no idea okay it's coming but
I still have no bloody clue where he is
I know it's he in front of me
imagine if he is I'll be so stupid
oh my God look at him oh yeah he scared
me he has a fabulous spirit thing that
was actually a really really interesting
game I love the idea of it having
folklore and trolls and an old Eric
which is another for glory thing I've
always wanted to see more games using
folklore like the Loch Ness and Bigfoot
and there's loads of things that would
make him awesome awesome game but I
don't really see them being used so much
but ya know to me the atmosphere was
brilliant the narrative seems really
cool it's obviously about mother who's
trying to find her son she's at a
counselling session
I think this one it seems like anyway
and she's talking him through her dream
so it sounds really interesting I'll put
a link in the description below for you
to have a go yourself and to see whether
it's still on Kickstarter or not and
give this a thumbs up if you enjoyed
have a lovely evening bye
he's gonna be behind me again yeah I
knew wait wait what oh my god there's oh
my god there's like ice of you guys why
you yeah why continue want me what do
you want me for